All right. Okay.
Welcome everyone to the DDP
seminar. today. Before we
introduce our invited speaker,
let's go over some rules and
logistics. First of all, please
mute yourself during the talk
unless you have questions. If
you have questions, you're
welcome to unmute and ask
otherwise, please use the chat
room to post your questions so
that we can address them in q&a
session at the end. Second,
today's DDPS seminar is open to
external audiences. Therefore,
no qualified discussion is not
allowed. Finally, the talk today
will be recorded and uploaded in
our YouTube channel. Alright,
let's introduce our speaker
today. It is an honor to host
Laurie Graham Bradley, who is a
professor and former chair of
the civil and System Engineering
Department at Johns Hopkins
University with secondary
appointments in mechanical
engineering and material science
and engineering. She currently
serves as director of the Center
on AI for materials in extreme
environments and Associate
Director of the Hopkins extreme
materials Institute. Our
research interests are in
machine learning enabled
mechanics models, uncertainty
quantification, computational
stochastic mechanics, multiscale
modeling of materials with
random micro structures, and the
mechanics of failure on the high
rate loading. She has received a
number of awards including the
Presidential Early Career awards
of scientists and engineers, the
Walter Hoover Civil Engineering
Research prize and William
Higgins award for excellence in
teaching. She is a fellow of the
ASC Engineering Mechanics
Institute and the US association
for computational mechanics.
Today, Laurie will talk about ml
driven models for material
microstructure and mechanical
behavior. Please enjoy and
expect a wonderful talk now
without further ado, let me pass
the baton to Lori by asking one
random question. Today's random
question is where is your
favorite place in the world?
Wow.
Other than here in my home?
That's a tough one. I've been to
so many beautiful places over
the years. I got to pick one.
I got to pick one. Well, I got
married in Lake Placid, New
York. So and I have a lot of
family history there. So Lake
Placid is, is a happy place for
me. If anybody hasn't been
there, I suggest you go visit.
Alright, sounds good. Okay,
stage is yours.
Great. Thank you. So thank you,
Jung Soo for inviting me. And I
appreciate everybody who is
here. And I hope I can deliver
on the wonderful talk that Jung
Soo just promised. But it's a
pleasure to talk to all of you.
And I wanted to start by giving
some, sorry, some credit to the
people who actually did a lot of
the work here, including my
group, including the PhD
students and postdoctoral
scholars, some of which I think
might be online right now. So
they'll catch me if I say
something wrong. And as well as
some of the staff that have been
really supportive of what we're
trying to develop here at
Hopkins. So the motivation for
all of this is thinking about
high throughput data driven
design. So I'm going to talk a
little bit about something that
we're building here called the
AI for materials design, in
extreme environments, AIMD
facility, and right now it's
under construction. So I wish I
had some beautiful pictures of
the lab itself. But right now,
it's pretty much drywall is
getting home at the moment. But
it's a 2300 square foot
facility, and it will integrate
material science, data science,
AI and robotics. And it's
specifically targeting right now
metal alloys, although we're
talking a little bit about
ceramics at the moment too, but
what does it have? So, in terms
of fabricating and processing
materials, we are planning or we
are using sputter deposition to
generate thick foils of these
alloy specimens using high
throughput carrot X ray
characterization, where we can
use for example, X ray
diffraction to understand the
crystal structure, and maybe a
little bit about average grain
size and X ray fluorescence to
understand the chemistry of the
specimens that we're looking at.
And then finally, thinking of
extremes, there's high
throughput laser shock. So with
that, we're looking at being
able to run tests, multiple
tests a minute and characterize
things like spa stir lengthen
ETL and some equation of state
parameters. So that's on the
sort of physical side, all of
this is getting integrated.
Okay, all of this is integrated
through robotic automation. So
maybe I'll give you some fun
videos of what we're talking
about here. So this is what the
layout will look like. It's sort
of a J shaped conveyance that
will move specimens from one
piece of equipment to another.
And the robotic arms will be
placing the equipment in and
removing the, or placing the
material in and removing from
the equipment. And this is what
it looks like. In reality, this
is actually at the vendor,
they're still working out some
of the kinks and we'll be
delivering it when the room is
ready for it. And the roboticist
and our team, Axel Krieger has
developed some simulations. So
on the left, you're seeing just
a video of what we call the
robotic arms dancing, but it
gives you an idea of that
there's sort of multiple things
happening at the same time. And
if you look at one particular
equipment, so this is the x ray
system, and going through the
simulation of how do you get a
small specimen? How do you pick
it up? How does it get
transmitted into the equipment,
with an X ray, you have a very
small aperture, you don't want a
lot of open apertures to the out
the environment outside for
safety reasons. So that actually
takes a lot of work to think
through those processes. So we
have a lot of robotics in play.
The other piece that's really
taking a lot of time is thinking
about data. And I think this is
a huge challenge for everybody.
There's a coordinated data,
there's controlling the
equipment, the metadata about
the materials, gathering, and
organizing and collecting the
results that we can use to make
on the fly decisions about the
processes that were the
experimental processes. And so
just to give you some idea of
all that's involved in the data,
on the left hand side is
representing physical systems.
So profilometry, laser shock, X
ray systems and robotics. In the
middle is the host machine, this
is the machine that's
controlling everything. And so
you can see the little person is
it and the application service
as and then there's all these
acronyms here, data services in
the middle that's basically
distributing and moving data.
And then arch is the sort of off
site facility where we send data
in there is an AI driver in
there that we're working on
local computing. And so just to
give you an idea, if you come up
with a script of something very
simple to do, all the steps of
where data has to fly from one
place to another in this system,
we have to think through all
these connections, and make sure
that they're all formatted in a
consistent way. So never
underestimate the data
management process. But beyond
that, to get to the meat of what
I want to talk about is that
that AI driver in there is going
to need fast computational
models, and some measures of
uncertainty in order to be able
to make effective decisions.
Now, the models actually don't
have to be perfect, what they
need to be able to do is say
that the model will predict that
situation A is better or
different or worse than
situation b. But it doesn't
necessarily mean that the model
has to be able to predict the
result down to you know,
precision 10 to the minus eight.
It's really, in this
environment, kind of a design
discovery environment. It's a
prediction of will something
change. So we can be a little
bit looser, and how we the
criteria we put on our models.
So what are the opportunities
here and why now so why develop
something like AMD? And I will
know that there are a lot of AI
for materials facilities out
there that are really
successful. I think what's
different about ours is that
we're trying to capture extreme
environments, dynamic
environments, and that's
traditionally something that
hasn't been easy to do in a high
throughput setting. So I think
the opportunities here are a few
that there's certainly a greater
ability to develop new
materials. So things like
additive manufacturing, and
advances in sputter deposition,
really enable a lot of new
materials. There's high
throughput characterization and
testing. We're talking about
processes that traditionally
might take hours or days being
able to be done in seconds.
Minutes. Or alternatively, maybe
surrogate tests that are very
fast, that we hope represent
something about a larger system.
We have more computational power
than ever, I always put an
asterisk on this statement.
Because no matter what we always
want more computational power.
We have, as scientists and
engineers, we have the ability
to fill the available
computational power with no
problem. And I think that could
go on to infinity. And then
finally, the uncertainty
quantification tools are
maturing. And I don't mean to
claim this as a mature field.
But it's, you know, all the good
works been done. But it's gotten
to the point where it's actually
practicable, you can actually
start implementing UQ practices
in real problems. And so just
the low res showing one example,
a very complex model. So in red,
I'm going to give the
counterpart to each of those
opportunities, sort of the
challenge that it presents, we
can develop many more new
materials, but it creates an
enormously high dimensional
design space. So if you think
about an ATA that has, say, five
element components, there's an
enormous number of possible
combinations of those. And
certainly the full continuum of
all the proportions of those
high throughput characterization
and testing is terrific, it
creates large quantities of data
that we have to deal with, we
have to deal with data flows,
and typically that data is low
fidelity. So you're balancing
sort of high throughput, low
fidelity data with a little bit
low fidelity, or high fidelity,
but very sparse data. And so
there's a tricky balance there.
True multi scaling, real models
of these systems are often
computationally infeasible, even
with a lot of computational
power. So we need clever ways to
attack that. And finally, UQ
adds cost. We're finding some
very good tools, but but it is
costly. So I can't address all
of those in this talk. But I do
want to think about the issue,
the slow models do create a
bottleneck for design decisions.
So if I'm thinking about our aim
D facility, if the laser shock
system is sort of asking, is it
worth testing this particular
specimen, and I send it to a
model that takes 24 hours to
answer, then I'm getting no
value from the fact that laser
shot can happen in minutes. And
so I don't want my models to be
so slow that any decision that's
made is waiting on some long,
slow running model, and need
have fast decisions. So I think
today, I'll focus on these two
particular pieces. One is, how
can we enhance the data we have?
So for example, can we enhance
high for low fidelity data to
create high fidelity data? And
how can we address multi scaling
in a way that's efficient? So
I'll start with the first one is
kind of a talk in two parts. So
here's our problem statement. If
we're given limited, three
dimensional, or even only two
dimensional data, could we
reconstruct a three dimensional
microstructure? Or better yet an
ensemble of those? So often, in
particularly in a high
throughput setting, you're not
given three dimensional
information? Is there a way for
us to take the two dimensional
information and generate micro
structures that have similar
characteristics? So again, our
goal is to generate an ensemble
of micro structures that match
what are key characteristics of
the microstructure? They're not
the same microstructure, a
different instantiation of the
same kind of microstructure. And
one challenge we face is that
traditional stochastic
simulation does not work well.
So there are a couple of
challenges here, say a binary
material like this is very non
Gaussian and its distribution,
right? It's basically two Dirac
delta functions, which is maybe
the extreme of non Gaussian
unity. So things like
translation processes to
generate microstructures won't
work, or at least won't work
very well. The other issue is
that these kinds of irregular
microstructures aren't as simple
as maybe a model where you'd say
I'm going to put, you know,
circular inclusions down in
space randomly. You can't use
that here. So what are some
descriptor descriptors that we
might want to think about? One
could be something like the two
point probability function,
which basically asks if I Put a
vector down randomly in the
space, what's the probability
that its two endpoints lie in
poor space. And so on the right
upper right, you can see
basically, a typical probability
function, its maximum is at
delta x delta y both equaling
zero, meaning you're comparing
the point to itself. So it makes
sense, those are appointed very
well correlated to itself. And
that sort of correlation dies
off as you go further away from
the the vector gets longer and
longer. Another characteristic
you might think about is a pore
size distribution, which
basically says if you pick a
random point in the pore space,
what is the distance to the
closest solid space. And a
typical function looks something
like what I'm showing here kind
of starts at a peak at zero and
dies out as you go to longer and
longer distances. Now, a problem
here is this. Two point
probabilities don't often
capture all the characteristics.
So these are some results from
actually a fairly old paper,
where a student and I were
working on a simulated annealing
approach to simulate these micro
structures. And we wanted to
match the two points,
statistics. So the upper row is
the original image. The second
row is a simulated image. And
the two points statistics are
the same between the first and
the second row. And what you see
is it's okay for the circular
inclusion microstructure on the
left the first one. But if you
look at the other three, there's
a lot of information lost shapes
conductivity, you see glimmers
of what the original
microstructure was, but it's
really not the same at all. And
we kind of hit a point where we
said, Well, we tried using three
point correlations, and then
improve the problem improve the
simulation somewhat, but it was
incredibly slow to do that. And
in the end, it came down to the
things that we see as people who
say, Well, this is more
squiggly, or that's more
connected. But that's not so
easy to quantify. So the what is
missing question kind of hung
out there, until we started
looking at some of the tools out
there related to machine
learning. So the idea here is to
use transfer learning. The VGG
19 network is a network that's
commonly used for recognizing
objects. So is this a picture of
a cat or a truck or an airplane.
And it performs that recognition
through a series of finding just
all sorts of features, I don't
even know there's no way to
describe them physically. But it
just works with that image and
identifies all the relevant
features that would make it
categorize into being a certain
object. So you can think of the
same thing with microstructure
we input a microstructure image.
And the VGG 19 model gives us a
sense of the feature maps, a
bunch of aspects that we don't
necessarily know how to
describe, but they're
quantifiable. And so how we can
use those networks is let's say
we have a target image, that we
will need to create another
image with the same
characteristics. So we can take
the target image and run it
through the VGG 19 model. And we
can do the same thing with a
simulated image. And we can just
start with white noise, and
compare the grim basis Graham
gram matrix for each of them.
And the loss is the difference
between those. So that last
tells you how far away is my
sort of initial simulation from
the target. And there are other
things that we can add to this
loss function like total
variation, which is basically
penalizing individual pixels,
like noise. So it's a way of
sort of reducing noise in the
image, but you can put whatever
you want into this loss
function. combine it together to
identify total loss, different
again, essentially difference
between the target and where you
are with your current image, and
asked Have I minimize, have I?
is the loss less than some
threshold? If it is, well,
great, we're done. We have a
reconstructed microstructure
that has a lot of the statistics
or the characteristics of the
original. If not, then I need to
update and basically the
algorithm uses a gradient based
optimization, sort of an atom
optimizer to update that image
and then we do the comparison
again, and we just keep going
and iterating and changing that
image until it matches our
target image in some reasonable
way. This actually was drawn
from some work by A way Chen's
group at Northwestern where they
just looked at the gram matrix
loss, and we've been playing
with what goes into the loss
function, in addition to that.
Alright, so I'm gonna do
something there.
So this optimization based
reconstruction, we match the
statistical descriptors. And the
VGG 19 feature maps from the
target. Another thing that we
added to the loss function was
the two point probability. So we
wanted to actually minimize the
difference in the two point
probability between the original
and the reconstructed. And on
the right, you can see sort of a
target. On the left is a quick
GIF of an image going from white
noise converging to a simulated
microstructure. So you can see
what happens is it iterates
through this process from
basically right now for fuzzy
white noise through to a final
image. And our final image, we
get a very good match and things
like the two point probability
function and the pore size
distribution function. So those
basic statistics look really
good. Now, that was just a
single image. And other thing we
thought about was, we have a
sample that it's actually a CT
scan of a three dimensional
porous ceramic, and it has 180.
It's one of its dimensions at
185. So we took each of those
slices, and treated it as one
sample from the material. So I
think the way to think about
this is, you have a material,
that's all, you know, some bulk
of material, it's all the same
material. But if you looked at
the microstructure in one
region, and in another region,
you will get different micro
structures. And so we wanted to
capture that variability. So we
went slice by slice. And you can
see that there's a variation in
porosity, and correlation
length, and in mean pore size
across all of these and again,
this is the experimentally
obtained data, the slices. Our
question was, do the
reconstructed microstructures
capture this. And so what we did
was for each slice, target
slice, we generated a simulated
slice. Again, you can see the
target and the simulated are not
the same thing, but they're
statistically similar. And we
went did that over the full 185
slices. And here, we're
comparing the Ricans
distribution of porosity, coral
length, correlation, length and
mean pore size in the
reconstructed in green, and the
target in blue. And if you look
at the means and the variances
below each plot, you can see
that we're essentially matching
definitely the mean, with almost
essentially no error and the
variance very well. And each of
these distributions, and the
distributions match over each
other quite well. Now, again,
there's a statistical sampling.
That happens here, that would
mean that we wouldn't expect the
distributions to be exactly on
top of each other, because these
are different instantiations of
similar statistics. So we match
those statistics. But is that
really sufficient? And that was
a question that we asked
ourselves. And we thought about
the idea that that reason, you
would typically want to generate
these virtual microstructures
like this is because you're
using them to model something.
So you're, you would typically
simulate a microstructure, put
it through some sort of finite
element model to develop some
sort of prediction. And so we
thought, probably a good way to
test this is to look at some
average properties that would be
predicted, based on finite
element models of the
microstructure. So what we did
is for every microstructure that
we simulated, we put it into a
finite element model, with
different properties for the
black and the white phase. And I
can't remember exactly, I
remember that the black phase
was typically high values, and
the white phase was low, we
didn't do full on pours, but she
doesn't think was like a low
stiffness or low conductivity.
And so then we predict the
stress distribution, the heat
flux distribution, and the
discharge distribution
associated with each of those
models. And overlaid that with
predictions from finite element
models of the original
microstructures. And again, you
see there's an excellent match
in the mean and the variance of
these quantities. Thermal
conductivity probably struggles
the most, and maybe if I go back
to that result for a second, you
can see the thermal conductivity
in the middle. It's very low.
localized sort of paths of heat
flux. So we would expect that
that would be a little more
difficult to predict than, for
example, the Youngs modulus,
which is like an average sort of
quantity. So that shows up here,
but even with thermal
conductivity, there's a really
strong match between the
simulated and the actual
microstructure statistics.
So, what have we accomplished
here? If you compare this to
simulated annealing, which was
sort of the more traditional
approach, the transfer learning
here was orders of magnitude
less time, and achieve
significantly superior results.
So at some point, we just ran
out of patience with the
simulated annealing and cut it
off before it converged all the
way. But this was, we're talking
hours versus minutes. And the
difference here, so you know, a
couple orders of magnitude
faster, to get a very good multi
loss based reconstruction on the
left. And we also were able to
apply this to a variety of
multi-phase materials, thinking
of polycrystal and kinds of
materials and get different
kinds of micro structures. If
you think about look at the top
and the bottom, they're both
poly crystalline, but they have
sort of different kinds of
features, and we're able to
capture that. So that's 2d. It's
interesting from the perspective
of being able to generate an
ensemble of, of microstructures.
But really, I think, what's more
exciting is the idea of being
able to go to full three
dimensional microstructure
simulation. So we go back to the
3d reconstruction. So this is
our basic image. This is again,
that porous ceramic, we've been
working with the images around
10 to the eighth, eighth voxels.
If we were to try to deal with
this full 3d structure and
optimize it, we'd be updating
about 10, Meg's of data at every
optimization loop would be
pretty much memory intensive.
And furthermore, the VGG 19. And
similar models aren't really yet
trained for 3d images. So
instead, what we're doing is
working with 2d slices of this
image. And that's much more
easily parallelized. So I'll
show you some of the results
here. So here's the idea. Think
about this 3d structure, you
start with white noise, that's
our starting condition. So every
pixel is randomly assigned black
or white, independent of the
pixels around it. And first, we
start thinking in the xy
direction, and we take each of
those white noise images, we run
it through our VGG 19 model, the
Transfer model. And we update it
so that it turns into what's
viable as a microstructure in
the 2d slices. Now, of course,
one slice is independent of the
next. So you have like, within
the slice, it looks good. But
across the slices, it won't look
as good. But so right now we
have, at this point, a deck,
think of a deck of cards, each
card has a reasonable
microstructure. But it's not
necessarily correlated to the
microstructure through the
cards. So you would end up with
something like this, actually,
it'd be even worse in the first
step, because they'd be totally
uncorrelated, but you have this
sort of banded pneus, that
happens, right? Because what you
did to one slice was independent
of what you did to the previous
slice and slice after it. Um, so
this interlayer noise occurs.
But it does converge over
iterations, if we do the
following. If we take, say, the
slices with a light blue, and
now that's our deck of cards in
that direction. And we take each
of those sort of banded noisy
images, we make that the initial
condition for another transfer
model, transfer learning model,
we generate microstructures in
that direction. And then we go
to the dark blue direction,
because now that's a little bit
banded in strange looking, and
we do the same thing, we go
through each slice. So that's
kind of highlighted here. This
is going in the x z direction,
we basically update the
microstructure in that x, z
direction. And then we update
the slices in the y, z
direction. So in the process of
doing this, what happened in the
xy direction, now we've kind of
messed up what was originally a
pretty good looking set of
microstructures within each
plane. So what we'll do is now
go pass through again, go in the
x, y direction, in the z
direction in the y, z direction,
maybe do three full passes, five
full passes. But what ends up
happening is, as you move
forward, you're having to change
fewer and fewer voxels. So
you're starting to see
convergence in all three
directions, that ultimately
plays out into a good 3d model
based on the 2d image. So again,
this is starting from a single
2d image and saying, if I assume
that the statistics are the same
in all the directions, I can go
ahead and generate a 3d
microstructure based on those
images. I could also have three
images, one in one in the xy
direction, one that's collected
in the y, z direction, and one
that's collected in the z
direction, if it's an an
isotropic material. And I could
follow the same process and
generate an an isotropic 3d
microstructure. So I'm not
limited to just isotropic. But
that's what I showed here. Okay,
so the statistics of these 3d
microstructures look pretty
good. They get better and better
as we iterate more through the
model, this is after three
passes, if we went through five
passes, they might even get
closer. So by three passes, I
mean that we went direction 1233
times, so sort of nine passes
through in different directions.
And the pore size distribution
also looks very good in this 3d
structure. We also use this to
look at polycrystalline
microstructure. So we have, we
only had the 2d slice that you
see above the upper left. And
from that, we generated a three
dimensional volume. That's
statistically, it has the same
characteristics as the 2d slice.
And actually, if you look at the
grain size distribution from A
to D cut outs of the 3d volume,
they match almost imperceptibly
that almost exactly was the
target. So these efficient
simulations, why do we want
them, there are a few different
reasons. One is, the experiments
are typically limited in the
amount that can be observed.
Right, so maybe you have a
system that can only look at 128
by 128 pixels or so you're
limited in the volume of
material that you can
characterize at a given
resolution. But what this tool
allows you to do is to actually
generate then similar
microstructures, that are
larger, you could go smaller to
but I think larger is probably
more motivating. So you're not
as limited in a model based on
the experimental observations,
you're not so limited by what
the experiment is able to
resolve. Another piece that this
enables is looking at the
uncertainty that's induced by
microstructure. So you can
generate an ensemble of micro
structures, and therefore get an
ensemble of responses. So you
can actually use that to feed a
model that would create your
would generate some sort of
uncertainty quantification. And
then the third reason, or the
third value of this is the
ability to go from a 2d image to
a set of similar 3d
microstructures. So if you have
a 2d reading of even in
different directions of what a
particular material looks like,
you can come up with a
reasonable representation of
what the 3d microstructure might
be. So that's my pitch for one
piece of trying to enhance data
that's serving a data driven
system like this. Yes.
This is a good time to ask about
the first part. Yeah, sure. I
have a question. No, the
transfer learning the VGG 19
model you you're using, it is
setting some multiple loss
functions, and you have to
minimize it. You said you use
the dance algorithm that takes
that takes time, right? So the
computational cost of that it's
not free. So when you compare
that competition, of course, to
the 3.3 point, you know, the
method of request reconstructing
the microstructure i, which one
is more expensive, but but
you're aiming to come up with a
more efficient method. So I
guess transfer learning must be
more efficient.
In some sense. It is it's it's
significantly more efficient. So
in the leading annealing kinds
of approaches is that you're,
you're typically doing some sort
of pixel swaps, maybe in batch,
but you're kind of taking small
numbers of pixels and you
perturb them. And then you ask
is this new version closer than
the old version? But there's no
gradients in it. So I think what
makes this approach faster is
using the gradient based
optimization step. Okay. So it's
sort of more intelligently
updating the microstructure,
then.
I see. But But still, it still
takes time, right? Those Those
VGG 19 model to solve that to
minimize the loss functions. It
does. It's
not like seconds. Yeah, right.
Right. Right. Yes. So I would
compare to to coin method,
that's, that's faster,
much faster. Yeah. So it's, you
can accomplish a ballpark, you
can accomplish what it would
take an hour to do with a
simulated annealing kind of
approach. It's in probably, I
don't know, half a minute. Now,
over a large number of these,
and over a large number of, you
know, as you try to converge it,
it still adds up. So I'm not
saying that it's free. It's not
something that comes up with no
effort at all. But it just
massively cuts down. I mean,
honestly, how we got here was we
were trying to use simulated
annealing for simulating a 3d
microstructure. And it just was
impossible. We couldn't get it
to go where we wanted it to go.
And so my clever student went
out and found some interesting
results in the literature. And
we've we started to pull from
that and actually found it just
made all the difference in the
world.
Sounds good. Okay. How many? Do
you have a lesson?
Yes. Hi, thank you. This is very
interesting. I just have a maybe
simple question. I've never done
anything about this before. It
doesn't make sense, or is it
efficient to like, reconstruct
these micro structures from case
space? Like, I would imagine
that two similar micro
structures would have similar
distribution in case space. Does
that make sense? Have you
considered something like that
before?
I haven't considered that?
That's a good question.
I haven't done another reason
why I'm thinking about case
space is that I would maybe also
assume that if you do a 2d
slides, and then you measure,
like the case, space
distribution, then if you want
to extend it to 3d, you can just
simply extend that distribution
in the other direction. And
then, I don't know, like, I'm
just thinking on the fly now.
Yes.
Does that mapping work? Well, in
a binary system?
I actually don't know that. This
is just all my imagination,
actually. So I was just
wondering if you considered it
in case space?
It's it's actually it's a very
good thought. I think what would
come up? Is these binary 01
systems are tricky. Oh, so you
can match the statistics, but
there's a lot of there will be a
lot of noise and things that you
don't catch. Yeah. Right. Yeah.
Thanks.
All right. Sounds good. I guess.
I don't know. We can move on to
the second part of you.
Excellent.
Okay. Well, and certainly if if
people think of questions during
the second part on the first I'm
happy to, yeah.
Yeah. Sounds good.
All right. So the next step is
thinking about multi scaling,
and how could we have you how
can we use machine learning for
multi scaling problems? And so
the idea here is what we need is
something fast a surrogate that
can enable real time decisions
and be able to link scales and
maybe even provide some UQ This
is actually a graphic that I I
lifted from Kaushik Bhattacharya
at Caltech that I like just the
concept of you have a large box,
you know, large processor that
can map inputs x two outputs y,
but you want some sort of small
fast, the Raspberry Pi that can
nap from some inputs to outputs
in a much faster way. And so
your focus just on mechanics of
simple two phase materials to
demonstrate an approach through
machine learning. So let me
start just first with an overall
problem statements, you have
some sort of structure with some
sort of load on it. In this
case, it's some sort of varying
pressure load. And that
structure at the macro scale has
a micro scale that for now,
we're assuming is some sort of
simple two phase composite. And
so if you wanted to go full on
naive, you would say, well, I
need a full scale finite element
model of this system. Within
each element, there is a local
microstructure. And I'm going to
mash that whole thing, all of
those 10,000 elements. And I can
come up with something like
let's say this is a stress
distribution. So yellow
indicates high stress, blue
indicates low stress. And we
capture the macroscale
variations and stress, but we
also capture things like, make a
little laser pointer here, to,
you know, force chains that
travel through some of these
fiber arrangements. Now,
clearly, we all know this, I
think anybody who's done any
significant computational
modeling, that's just not the
way to go, we can't resolve
everything at one scale and the
next scale, at least not for
really interesting problems. So
the conventional multiscale FDM
approach is to say, well, I'm
going to take each element, and
I'm going to extract its
microstructure. Use that to
homogenize the material and
figure out some effective
properties. So right now I'm
sticking with linear elasticity.
future direction as we move into
nonlinear actually future slash
current, but I don't have
results for that, that I'm going
to show today. So let's just
stick with linear elasticity.
And the material could be
orthotropic, and come up with
these effective properties. You
put those back into your finite
element model for each element.
And you can get a distribution
of average stresses. And you can
see that there's not a lot of
variability in this, that
doesn't come from the macroscale
loading, though there are areas
in here and in here, where
there's some effect of those
variations in microstructure.
But it's pretty small
variations. What you can do now
is take each element and say,
well, this element is undergoing
some strain state that's
predicted by the model. And
given that strain state, I'd
like to figure out what is the
stress at the microscale and
each of those elements. So
there's basically a downscaling
step going from the upper scale
to the lower scale. And so using
a finite element model, you
would take the microstructure
apply that strain that's
associated with that element,
that state of strain, and you
predict some stresses coming out
of it. And this is nice, because
it's parallelizable, it reduces
the computational time. But it
is still a lot of finite element
analyses. And it turns out to be
still quite costly. And, in
particular, you're having to
sort of resolve sufficiently the
inter fiber regions with enough
of a fine enough mesh to get
some realistic results. So what
we're looking at is a
representation that maybe uses
some finite element results. So
you do need the finite element
results as training data, but
then being able to just take an
arbitrary microstructure. And
from that, sort of take it in
squeeze it into a cube that
Wally does with it, and spit it
out into some stress. So an
output stress distribution. So
the first thing we need is the
training data. And so I'll walk
through that, and then I'll walk
through the architecture that
we're talking about for the
machine learning. Um, so from
the training data, we need of
finite element model of the
microstructure. So for each
microstructure, you can imagine
that we could apply a unit
tensile strain, and come up with
three this is a plane stress
problem, the way I've we've
formulated it, that you have
three different stresses coming
from that the to axial plus the
shear. And then you could apply
a unit shear strain. And again,
get three stress distributions
could also do strain
distributions, if that's of
interest. And so now for each
microstructure in your training
data, you'd have six sort of
output data associated with
that. So we want to train the
model to be able to go from
microstructure to those six
outputs. So we ran 50 models of
the microstructure, and got
basically 50 times six stress
distributions. And then we were
able to do one sort of cute
trick that helps. So think about
the original microstructure.
This shows just six fibers,
that's only for illustration,
our actual calculations have
more fibers in each one, but
this just makes it easier to
see. So you have an original
microstructure that maps to some
stress distribution, imagine
that this is maybe an axial
strain. And this is distress in
that axial direction, I can take
that same microstructure, if I
were to flip it around the
vertical axis, the stress
distribution would just be also
flipped accordingly. So because
everything about the problem is
symmetric, it's symmetric
loading, I can do the same
thing, I can flip it around the
horizontal axis, again, I just,
if I say the microstructure or
the upside down of what it was
before, the stress distribution
would just be the upside down of
that. And then I can do it one
more time flipping again, about
the vertical axis. And so
basically, each piece of data, I
can turn into four pieces of
data. It's there's no free
lunch. This is it helps. But
it's not the same as having an
independent piece of data. But
it actually does give quite a
bit of information to the model.
So it's, it would say the model,
the model doesn't know the
physics, it might look at the
stress distribution on the upper
left and think, Well, something
happens typically in the upper
right corner of these models.
And what these other pieces will
do is sort of eliminate some of
that bias, let's see is that
cemetery. Alright, so we have an
augmented data set, now we have
four times 50, microstructures,
and four times 50 times six
data, even though we only ran
50. And so the architecture
we're looking at is called a
unit. It's a form of a
convolutional neural net. The
idea is you have an input, image
and output stress tensor fields.
And the mapping between those is
through a series of convolutions
going down to a latent space,
that then is decoded back up to
the output. And then there is
what are called the skip
connections that basically
recognize that there is some
form to the microstructure that
should influence what the
results look like. And so it
kind of brings some of the
microstructure and output
connections into play. And so
what we're doing when we train
basically is training all the
weights in this encoder decoder
process. And then we get an
input to output mapping. Of
course, once trained, running
any image through this is like a
trivial computational effort. So
unit predictions, this is a
microstructure that was not part
of our training set. And this is
the prediction of the stress
distribution that came out of
that unit model. So the upper
row corresponds to a unit
tensile load, and the lower
bottom row corresponds to unit
shear strain. And we can do a
comparison between finite
elements. And unit again, this
is not part of the training set.
So for this microstructure, the
finite element prediction is
shown on the left the unit
prediction shown in the middle.
And then this gives us a sense
of the absolute error. The error
is small, there's one region
where it's higher than the rest,
but even there, it's less than
10% error. So that's the stress
in the direction of the strain,
the transverse stress and the
shear stress, and so we have
very good agreement between
them.
Similarly, if we apply a shear
strain, we have very good
agreement between the two axial
and the shear stress. And since
I started with linear elastic
problems, I can take advantage
of superposition. So I can say
the total strain is a sum of
factor tensor tensile loading
plus the shear loading to give
me any general loading condition
I've got so if my finite element
model has a certain strain
state, I can use superposition
to find the stresses for that
arbitrary strain state. So very
simple for finite four element
finite element model. I don't
suggest a four element model to
anybody but this is just a nice
illustration under tensile
loading, the unit can predict
the stress distribution in each
of those four regions under Unit
loading. And use that take the
averages of those to find the
constitutive relations for each
of the elements. When those are
put back into the finite element
model, it gives us an average
strain tensor for every element,
and or average stress. That is
the result of variations in the
microstructure from one element
to the next, we apply those
strains, sorry, to the unit
model, and we get a stress
distribution. And putting it all
together, it looks like this. So
this is, again, purely using the
unit model. There's no finite
element in here other than the
finite element model two by two
elements, the macroscale. And if
I compare that to a full scale
finite element model where the
fibers are all exactly resolved,
I have really great agreement.
And this was like trivial on the
right, this is a two by two
finite element model with like
simpler implementation of the
unit. The only difference you
see is along here, where there's
the element boundary. But that's
a problem in any multi scaling.
paradigm. So if we use Fe
squared, we would have the same
thing. Anytime you extract part
of the model and analyze it
separately, you'll have some dis
continuity at the interface. So
we can show the same thing for
something with a much more
refined mesh. This is the true
stress map from the full finite
element model. This is predicted
from the unit model. This on the
right, took seconds to run this
on the left took days to run.
But you get all the same kinds
of force chains that you can
see. And actually, one thing I
should point out is you can kind
of see a grid here, because
there are no fibers on the
boundaries in the way we train
the model. Since then, we did an
analysis where we looked at
fibers that cross boundaries, it
doesn't create any problems for
the unit. So we can vary the
volume fraction, we can vary the
fibers sizes, we can put the
fibers at the boundaries. This
is all from a single trained
unit model. And the predictions
sort of this is I should have
labeled the sorry, the left I
think is the finite elements in
the right is the unit model, we
get excellent results in all
these cases. So we can apply
this to an arbitrary geometry,
basic ideas, macroscale behavior
to homogenize and get our sort
of average stress or strain
state, run that through the unit
model is trivially fast to run
and get our microscale behavior
and put that back and we get a
much richer picture of the
overall stress distribution in
this system. Yeah, so to
conclude, this deep learning is
terrifically fast, and it's
accurate for predicting the
microscale stresses. It provides
a really efficient multi scaling
approach or a composite, and
some things that are in
progress. And elasticity and or
dynamic behavior, we're tackling
by treating that as sort of a an
added dimension to the problem.
So it's another dimension that
we'll have to train for. We
could also look at three
dimensional microstructures. So
this was really just showing you
2d. It also enables deep
learning based uncertainty
quantification, both in terms of
uncertainty of the model
predictions. Also another piece
of this is we're looking at
uncertainty quantification for
the CNN architecture. So what
kinds of uncertainties are
introduced by even using this
model. And then finally, the the
animation is showing you how
quickly we can analyze the
system just moving fibres
around, right, so we can get the
updated stress distribution very
fast. This made us think that
there's a real opportunity for
thinking about topology
optimization here, where you
could think about what what
should be the placement of
inclusions in a two phase system
that would maximize or minimize
some particular behavior? So
those are all the things that
we're thinking about. This is
actually a picture of the lab I
was describing earlier, the AIMD
lab when it becomes available,
so I don't think there'll be
shadowy figures hanging out so
much when it's up and running.
So we're looking forward to that
sometime this summer. It's
gotten a lot of support from the
university and Army Research
Labs has been a big supporter
Read this. And it's all run
through the center and AI for
materials in extreme
environments. So thank you. Any
questions?
Thank you. Thank you so much for
the wonderful talk. Laurie. We
do have a question, Adam, just
raise your hand. Can you unmute
and ask question? Yeah. Can
you guys hear me? Yes. Hi,
Laurie, this is very exciting,
very awesome talk. So it seems
like superposition is doing a
lot of the legwork here for you
to be able to take the data that
you're training for all those
simple strain states and
extrapolate. So can you talk a
little bit about your strategy,
when you go into nonlinear
regimes or plasticity, something
like that? And are you just
going to need way more data? Or
what what's going on there?
Yeah, it's a good question. So
there's a couple of different
ways to think about it. One is
if, if you knew, if it's just a
problem of it being inelastic,
and you know, the load path
you're traveling through, it's
actually not too bad of a
problem, because you can train
it. For example, we could treat
the the results as a three
dimensional entity, right? Where
you have each slice in three
dimensions is the state as
you're loading up. Yeah. So you
could capture that behavior. And
that's actually quite doable.
And we've been able to
accomplish some some work there.
The challenge, I think, in multi
scaling is that you don't know
the load path a priori. So you
don't know this integration
point is gonna go up here and
over here and down. And so I
think there has to be some
training over possible viable
load paths. And or what I think
is actually more hopeful, is to
think of it the same way finite
elements does, right. So you're
in a certain state right now.
And you're advancing forward in
a particular load step. So you'd
have to think about, can I train
my model to understand what
happens in in a load step? So
that it's not like having to
think about the whole path, the
load path that it follows? Does
that make sense?
Yeah. So that's at least one
more dimension to your problem,
but possibly more?
Yeah, it's tricky, I think, in
the multi scaling. So it's
something that we're trying to
wrap our heads around right now.
And I do think that the
incremental approach is probably
the load incremental approach is
the way to go. Okay,
thank you very much. Thanks.
Sounds good.
I have a maybe brilliant idea,
too. I love it. So if you go to
slide 61.
So in order to enrich the data
to train the unit, you you, you
know, take advantage of the
symmetry, right? Okay, on top of
that, you can enrich more by
just, you know, translating the
microstructure by translational
translational symmetry,
basically, so you have a small
units, and then that's just
looking at that individual chunk
in discrete sense. Why don't you
smoothly move? Right, that will
create a lot more data, and you
do have the corresponding stress
fields? Right. So that's another
way of enriching the data. And
then, you know, as everyone
knows, you net or any other
neural network, Big Data helps,
right. So I think that will
improve the unit and performance
by end. Yeah, yeah, you're
thinking kind of a moving window
over.
Exactly, exactly. Yes. And, you
know, continuation. On to the
Adams questions, if you go to
the time dependent path
dependence, the material, you
said that, you're going to
introduce the time window, right
there, you can also think about
moving the time window, likely.
Start with a some small time
window, I mean, you do have the
data for the longer longer time,
but make it short, and then just
translate slowly. Those chunk,
and then, you know, build the
unit on three dimensional X, Y
and, and that time domain, and
that's another video. But when
you slide the window, what the
boundary condition, like,
because I assume that here for
each little blog, you apply some
kind of uniform boundary
condition. Then when you slide
the window, the solution is not
a solution of that particular
boundary condition. Is that
correct?
That's right. So yeah, I think
you wouldn't have the same. So
what's consistent here is that
the boundary condition is always
that uniform strain boundary
condition. And we would lose
that in a moving window. But in
a sense, the flip. So something
I didn't really touch on here is
you can train this model on
these relatively small, I
wouldn't say six fibers, but
maybe 20 fiber model, those are
pretty quick analysis to do, and
you can perform a number of
them. What's interesting about
it is that it captures enough of
the local physics, that it
actually has potential to be
applied to a much larger domain.
So in in a sense, that sort of
the reverse of what you're
saying, you can say that you can
actually use training on the
small pieces to tell you
something about a large piece
without even creating,
necessarily the multiscale.
Like, without the full
multiscale finite element
framework around it. It turns
out, it tells you a lot about
the statistics locally, even in
a larger system. Making sense.
And the other issue, I think
with the time, I think you get
your point about sort of
averaging over time, the
challenge you've run into there
is that it's not statistically
homogeneous. It's changing with
time. So what's happening in
this part of the time might be
very different than what's
happening here.
So yeah, it's a good thought,
though.
It is potentially brilliant, I
have to think.
Sounds good. Hopefully, it
remains to be brilliant. All
right. Is there any other
question?
I just wanted to say to Henry's
point that once you go into a
nonlinear regime, you're not
able to cleanly superimpose the
simple strain boundary
conditions anyway. So knowing as
long as you know what the stress
and strain on the boundary of
your window are, and you track
that as well in the data, that
might not be a huge problem.
That's a good point. If there's
an advantage to having a large
system that you have a model of
and then you want to sort of
locally average across, you
absolutely could you could
measure the stresses and strains
on the boundaries of those local
regions, just the same way.
So now the idea remains to be
brilliant, I think. All right.
Sounds good. All right. We have
a question from see one. Tony,
do you want to unmute yourself
and ask?
Yes. Thanks, Larry, for the
great talk. Yeah, I learned a
lot. But I want to ask about the
comparison of the fella element
prediction. And then unit
prediction, I think is first
lies behind this, but I'm not
sure. So I want to ask if you
have any insights on how to
incorporate such like over
sampling techniques in the unit
model to suppress the resonance
along along the boundaries, as
we do in most multiscale
methods?
So I'm not sure I completely got
the question. You were talking
about the issue of maybe let me
go to uh, yeah.
I'm not sure if
people here. Yes. So you said
there's some, like,
discrepancies along the
boundaries. I, I don't know if
it if we describe the same same
issues with the same terms in
like reservoir simulation, and
in like materials as but so I
think this is called a resonance
effects in multi scale file, and
then methods when they apply to
like reservoir simulations. So
we have like over sampling
methods to try to reduce the
resonance error, but I'm not, I
want to ask if this applies to
your problems. And do you have
any insights on how to
incorporate these techniques in
the unit model?
You should be able to actually
do the same thing, right? So you
could build the unit model to
represent let's say, you know,
oversampled region. And then
there's, you'll have overlap
between regions. But you can do
the same sort of, I would
imagine even just sort of linear
filtering, right, you could sort
of average the results from two
overlapping subsequent unit
models, which I believe that's
what's done in the multiscale
finite elements to or some, you
know, more complex version of
that. But yeah, we didn't even
think about that. And as I say,
I kind of didn't touch on the
fact that we found that in fact,
the unit model is More powerful
than we thought. And we don't
necessarily have to even stick
to this finite element construct
to get some pretty interesting
results. But we just those
results aren't quite there yet.
So I wasn't ready to bring them
up today. But I think you're
hitting on exactly what we
found, too. There is some way to
use over sampling to kind of
smooth out some of these
discrepancies at the element
boundaries. I see. Yeah, sounds
good. Okay.
Question from Tom. Tommy, do you
wanna meet?
Hi, Laurie, thanks. It was a
great talk. Have you applied any
of these methods to carbon fiber
composites? Seems like that
would be an easier problem,
because you have the fibers that
would transmit stresses. Yeah,
we didn't actually go to a
specific composite system here,
right here, I think it was some
generic composite with. I can't
ever remember the contrast
ratio, maybe 10 to one or 15 to
one or something like that. But
there's absolutely no reason it
could be applied to any
combination of now elastic
properties that we'd like. So it
could absolutely be a carbon
fiber composite. And I think,
actually think about real
composites, I think going to a
three dimensional system is
really exciting, because then we
could start getting into things
like weave and waviness and some
of the out of plane behavior.
That's really important. Thanks,
Lori.
Thank you. Is there any other
questions from the audience?
Well, if not, let's thank Laurie
for the wonderful talk and
wonderful q&a sessions. And
hopefully there after this talk,
there will be some collaboration
is going to go on between
Lawrence Livermore, and Lori,
your groups. That's the whole
idea.
I hope so. I enjoyed this very
much. And absolutely. I hope
anybody who has any questions
should feel comfortable getting
in touch with me. And, you know,
maybe I would even pass you on
sometimes to some of my students
and postdocs who could really
get into. They know all of the
details.
Awesome. Awesome. Well, thank
you, Laurie.
Thanks so much. Thank you